the Mississippi River is drying up
water levels are approaching record lows
barges are getting stuck on sandbars and
unprecedented numbers many ports and
docks no longer have water deep enough
for commercial boats to safely reach
them and this is a problem for the whole
country
the Mississippi River a lot of people
just think of it as this beautiful large
historic River in the middle of the
country but really it serves as a
transportation Highway for a lot of
Industry the river is a critical
shipping route for agriculture oil and
building materials and the Mississippi
Watershed which includes all the Creeks
streams and lakes that feed into the
Mississippi river is the largest in the
U.S farmers in Iowa they harvest their
soybeans and they put them on barges and
send them down to the port below New
Orleans and then it's sent to China
chemicals are processed in Louisiana and
sent up River to the Ohio to factories
in Pittsburgh the central part of this
country thrives in part on industry
moving goods and services Up and Down
the River October is traditionally a
month of low water on the Mississippi
but this year the river's water levels
are approaching lows not seen since
1988. and if that's the case the river
at certain points is just going to shut
down for commercial traffic the water
has gotten so low that a shipwreck was
exposed along the banks of the river in
Baton Rouge Louisiana earlier this month
archaeologists believe it sank in 1915.
in recent weeks there have been over 20
blockages on the river and backups of
thousands of barges per day when a barge
gets stuck on a sandbar it's a real
expensive mess another barge has to come
you have to bring equipment to remove
that material and put it in another
barge to the point where it will float
enough so that it can get off The
Sandbar in some cases the tow boats
which pulled dozens of barges each have
hit sandbars so hard that the barges
they're Towing disconnect and that's
dangerous for Bridges and other boats
Riverboat Cruises have also halted due
to low water levels industry leaders say
if water levels stay this low or get
even lower the tourism industry will
take a massive hit so what's causing the
river to dry up it just did not get
enough rain this year particularly in
the upper Ohio River Valley normally
this is hurricane season in the South
some hurricanes will plow into the
United States and then become enormous
rainstorms that go up into the Ohio
River Valley and dump a lot of rain that
didn't happen this year and industries
that rely on the river to transport
Goods don't have many Alternatives it's
not as though a farmer can just run to
the railroad and that solves the problem
the rail system is so pressed right now
and they have Labor shortage issues they
have capacity issues that they're
running into but sticking with the river
will be costly for Farmers normally
shipping along the Mississippi River is
the cheaper option but with fewer boats
and barges able to transport Goods
prices have shot up for example the cost
of sending a ton of corn soybeans or
other grains from St Louis to Southern
Louisiana has jumped over 380 percent
since October 2021. the fall harvest
season which usually peaks in October is
the busiest time for agricultural
products if you can't get a rail line
out your soybeans are just sitting in
open field I mean a lot of farmers are
hesitating to even Harvest right now but
if they're let's say there are massive
rainstorms and your soybeans are just
sitting out there that could really
really really be disastrous this
disruption along the river comes at a
time when the warn Ukraine has prompted
huge demand for American agricultural
products and farmers were very excited
they can't get their stuff to Market
they can't get it to Market not easily
and not cheaply
over the last few weeks the U.S Coast
Guard has imposed restrictions on the
depth that commercial boats and barges
can sit in the water and on the number
of barges that toes can pull both
actions are to try to stop barges and
boats from getting stuck but industry
leaders say it's not enough there's no
real answer except for the rain there's
hope that beginning around December rain
will start to fall in the Ohio River
Valley to an extent where it'll start to
bring that water back down to the
Mississippi and things will get better
if not we're all in a lot of trouble
[Music]